je vous parlais il y a quelques jours
des Samsung Galaxy S23 qui sont sortis
ça y est alors moi j'ai le S23 ultra
avec moi il est là il est beau il est
chaud dans cette vidéo je vais vous
montrer les premières photos les
premières vidéos je suis allé dehors je
suis shooté deux jours de nuit j'ai une
première rendu où je vais vous montrer
un peu à chaud pourquoi parce qu'en fait
ce smartphone il m'intéresse énormément
c'est la première fois depuis le Galaxy
S6 qu'on retrouve un processeur de
Qualcomm à l'intérieur le syndrigon 8
GN2 qui est vraiment axé sur
l'intelligence artificielle donc je
voulais vraiment voir ce que ça venait
raconter ici en terme de performance
notamment au niveau de la photo et
notamment au niveau de la vidéo parce
que si on a quand même un gros capteur
de 200 mégapixels et que le truc est
vachement dingue et j'arrive pas à
ouvrir la boîte ouvre-toi la boîte donc
on regarde ça et puis à la fin je vous
dirai j'ai fait un benchmark sur en
toutou et je vais vous dire au final ce
smartphone comment il se positionne
notamment par rapport au Xiaomi 13 pro
que j'ai ici sur lequel j'ai déjà fait
un matchmark voir si il est à la hauteur
s'il est intéressant est-ce que ça
raconte vous êtes prêt on y va vous êtes
prêt accrocher à vous ça va durer
longtemps mais ça va être super
passionnant allez on y va
[Musique]
regardez alors la boîte je vous montrer
rapidement il y a globalement pas grand
chose bien évidemment pas de bloc de
charge ici je crois même que si est-ce
que j'ai un câble si j'ai un petit câble
qui est planqué là pour venir le charger
usb-c usb-c de courir mon tiroir de
carte SIM mais c'est tout c'est très
simple alors le truc dont on parlez
l'autre jour ça me saoule qui est cool
il disait nous on va plus sur
l'éco-responsabilité et on va mettre
plus de plastique recyclé dans nos
smartphones du vert recyclé de
l'aluminium recyclé donc ça c'est
vachement bien et ils nous disent on met
une petite feuille ici en papier en fait
au lieu d'avoir un film plastique
lorsque vous venez déballer votre
smartphone donc ça c'est cool c'est le
côté éco-responsabilité je trouve ça
bien mais ils vont pas jusqu'au bout de
la démarche ça c'est un peu con je vous
l'avais déjà dit ça me saoule en fait
ils mettent toujours des petits films
plastiques autour et je pensais qu'ils
allaient les virer et bien en fait il
faut croire que non parce que regardez
lorsque je viens prendre ici et bien
j'ai un film plastique qui ne sert
strictement à rien soyons très clair ça
ne sert ça strictement à rien mais pour
autant ça me saoule nous met donc je
trouve ça con en fait je trouve ça bien
d'avoir cette démarche je trouve ça bien
de dire ça mais lorsque vous me laissez
là vous voyez des grands films
plastiques sur la tranche et bien je
trouve que
parce que la démarche elle est là ils
nous disent plus de plastique à usage
unique dès 2025 et pour autant et ben ça
c'est un truc tout bête je pense qui
pourrait virer très facilement et il le
laisse voilà donc ça ça me fait un peu
pester et je tenais à le dire ça me
saoule quitte à faire les choses et
c'est très bien de les faire il faut
aller jusqu'au bout il faut me virer
tous ces buts de plastique globalement
de servi à rien et c'est très con les
avoir ici donc ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point c'est la partie photo
alors la partie photo je veux vraiment
qu'on en parle parce que vous avez
vraiment cinq caméras avec votre capteur
principal qui est là c'est 200
mégapixels qui est vachement cool avec
un super quad pixel en autofocus ça
c'est vachement bien c'est très
intéressant on va avoir un ultra grand
temps qui situe juste là c'est un 12
mégapixels ok vous avez votre
téléobjectif alors là c'est le X 3
optique en X 10 optique qui va jusqu'au
space zoom fois 100 voilà la promesse
qui est faite ici et vous avez votre
caméra de selfie à la vente 12 méga
pixels ok tout je trouve très très cool
alors on va commencer à regarder les
images parce que je suis allé me balader
bien évidemment vous en doutez on va
commencer tout de suite par des photos
de nuit parce que oui l'idée ici c'est
qu'on a un gros capteur de 200
mégapixels et que votre smartphone en
mode nuit va venir travailler regroupant
différents pixels pour pouvoir vous
sortir une photo avec avec une qualité
optimale alors c'est vraiment un premier
géant des premières photos on dira plus
loin dans quelques temps lors du test
donc pensez à vous abonner et à
actionner la cloche pour être notifié
quand la prochaine vidéo arrivera
d'autant plus qu'on va parler très
bientôt des S23 et S23 plus également on
va voir plein de choses dessus ça c'est
très très chouette donc là je suis venu
shooter je suis pas en bonne nuit je
mettrai une bonne nuit un petit peu
après c'est plutôt pas mal on peut venir
zoomer sur Montmartre derrière sur la
basilique très rapidement mais la nuit
on va venir éviter pareil de la même
manière ici là je suis allé sur la
défense alors je suis toujours pas en
mode nuit je peux passer sur l'ultra
grand-angle mais je vais éviter ultra
grand-angle la nuit qui est pas terrible
et puis je peux venir me rapprocher
zoomer bon très clairement je vais venir
éviter j'ai fait le même exercice ici
sur la Tour Eiffel on voit que la photo
à l'ultra grand-anglais lui c'est pas
nouveau mais on va venir éviter puis on
peut venir se rapprocher là ça
fonctionne par contre ça c'est une photo
qui est prise avec le mode nuit alors il
y a une vraie différence entre le mode
nuit que vous avez là et la photo qui
est prise sans le mode nuit vous le
voyez au niveau des habitations au
niveau des éclairages là et bien avec le
mode nuit c'est quand même vachement
différent c'est beaucoup mieux ça
ressemble mieux regarde les façades des
bâtiments là sont beaucoup mieux exposés
là c'est pareil c'est bien exposé on a
toutes les lumières là qui sont vraiment
respectées ce mode nuit est très bien
avoir une pause un peu plus longue comme
l'autre jour on va jusqu'à 5 secondes
ici en tout cas moi j'ai pu avoir 5
secondes de pause longue mais ça
fonctionne au niveau du ciel ça me va au
niveau des nuages ça me va je trouve ça
bien alors pareil à l'intérieur ces
petites photos comme ça et avec le
dragon angle on va oublier le dragon
mais je trouve qu'il y a des gens qui
sont assez joli au niveau de la gestion
vous voyez des lumières qui vont être un
peu plus fortes là ça va c'est bien
pareil ici de la même manière et là
c'est pareil mode nuit avec des façades
de bâtiments que je trouve bien exposé
que je trouve juste que je trouve jolie
il y a une belle esthétique là j'aime
bien l'esthétique une belle ambiance
c'est assez doux sur cette photo là donc
là je trouve ça joli alors par contre je
suis allé un peu plus loin dans la rue
avec l'arc de triomphe que vous avez au
fond et là ça déconne un petit peu au
niveau des éclairages publics donc c'est
des choses que je vais venir creuser
dans le test qu'on regardera un peu plus
tard ça nous montre un petit peu ça
c'est joli j'adore cette photo elle se
trouve très très douce la lumière est
super douce c'est très jolie et là il y
a un truc qui déconne un petit peu donc
là je suis en train de filmer avec mon
S23 ultra je vais tout filmer à
l'extérieur avec le S23 ultra je vais
vous montrer des photos des vidéos vous
allez voir tout cas c'est marrant donc
on fait une pour l'instant en 4K UHD à
60 images par seconde et on va aller
faire quelques photos on va commencer
par 200 mégapixels pour voir ce que ça
raconte lorsque je suis en 200
mégapixels regardez la qui est juste ici
j'ai le choix entre 50 200 et après je
dis 4/3 16 9 et compagnie donc là je
reste en 200 en fait en 200 hop là
j'appuie ici et là je vais retrouver ce
menu là avec un foyer dur ça c'est que
du numérique en fait donc là vu que le
capteur est 200 mégapixels à mon avis je
sais pas si la photo elle s'en
réellement de son megapixel regardez on
l'a fait on verra après je vais aller
jusqu'à un x 4 x 6 ça c'est le max que
je pourrais avoir ici je peux pas aller
au-delà oui ça c'est vraiment le maximum
que je peux avoir donc là on est sur des
photos qui sont posées avec le 200
mégapixels alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est l'âge sans perdre de qualité
regardez je peux venir là et en fait là
cette photo elle reste de bonne qualité
alors la différence et vous allez avoir
un travail algorithmique qui va être un
petit peu moins loin je vous montrerai
un peu plein dans la vidéo parce que je
suis venu comparer sur la même photo au
même endroit 200 50 et 12 mégapixels
vous allez voir il y a différents modes
qui permettent d'avoir ça mais ce que je
trouve intéressant une fois de plus
c'est le fait de se dire je peux venir
recoper vous voyez si je veux pas me
recadrer mon image comme ça et bien
c'est pas mal alors je peux venir trop
loin mais je peux presque lire je suis
au jardin Arnaud Beltram vous voyez
alors bon il y a un moment il y a la
limite quand même de ce qu'on a ici mais
globalement il y a du détail je trouve
que c'est pareil au niveau des briques
il y a du détail qui est vraiment là et
si vous voulez venir résumer dans une
photo et bien vous pouvez venir le faire
ici donc ça c'est très très chouette
pareil ici même chose je peux venir lire
ce qui est écrit ici voyez jeux de
ballon strictement interdit alors bon on
est limite on vient zoomer dans le truc
mais si vous voulez des photos et que
vous voulez venir ensuite à l'intérieur
venir recadrer vous n'êtes pas sûr de
votre cadre et bien vous pouvez venir
shooter en 200 mégapixels il faut qu'il
la lumière alors là les conditions voyez
lumière elles sont pas totalement
optimisées mais c'est pas dégueu non
plus l'appareil je suis ici je peux
venir recadrer si je le souhaite si je
vends le vin peut les là vous voyez et
bien je vais pas particulièrement perdre
de qualité j'ai toujours des bagnoles là
de toute façon donc je suis à Paris il y
a un moment il y a des bagnoles c'est
comme ça il y a des voitures mais
regardez je peux venir voir un petit peu
je peux venir lire les noms des rues
enfin je trouve ça pas mal honnêtement
après avoir ce qu'on pourrait bien faire
il y a un mode spécial roi il y a
allemand qu'on peut venir avoir sur
vraiment optimiser ses photos et faire
de la retouche mais là déjà pour avoir
une belle définition et venir recoper
son image et bien avec le 200 mégapixel
on peut alors cette rue je l'aime bien
là ça se trouve un peu dégueu comme ça
mais j'aime bien le fond que je trouve
un peu très provençal avec un resto qui
est très sympa ici alors bon il y a un
moment il y a la limite là j'ai mis un
peu trop loin dans l'image mais je peux
me dire un petit peu résumé donc bon moi
j'aime bien ces fichiers ils sont
vraiment pas mal donc là on était en 200
mégapixels maintenant on va essayer en
50 mégapixels et pour choper du 50
mégapixels on vient en photo on va juste
là et on clique ici sur 50 mégapixels
c'est parti là on regarde maintenant sur
le 50 mégapixels alors bon c'est pareil
l'idée du 50 mégapixels si vous voulez
c'est que on part toujours du capteur de
200 mégapixels mais là où avant on avait
chaque pixel qui venait restituer un
bout de l'image là par contre on va
regrouper on va faire du pixel Bining
prendre 4 pixels et les regrouper pour
faire un seul même les grands pixel ça
servira lorsque vous aurez moins de
lumière donc on aura un peu plus de
luminosité ici mais on dira moins loin
en termes de zoom on dira moins loin en
termes d'informations qu'on peut venir
récupérer pour venir recadrer alors
toujours venir recadrer un petit peu
mais il y a un moment il y aura un peu
plus de limite vous voyez que ce que
j'avais avec le capteur principal de 200
mégapixels donc là on est effectivement
sur le 50 mégapixels qui est très bien
je trouve franchement le fichier et bien
il est vraiment de bonne qualité là je
suis venu shooter un truc un peu plus
obscur alors là je vais voir un peu
moins de contraste mais pour autant ça
fonctionne là je trouve ça aussi très
très bien vous voyez au niveau du du 50
mégapixels pour moi le taf est fait et
ici une fois de plus photo prise au 50
mégapixels regardez la différence on va
se prendre la même photo avec le 200
mégapixels de 50 mégapixels et ensuite
le 12 mégapixels et on va regarder d'un
point de vue de détails ce qu'on peut
venir faire et ça change des choses en
terme de couleur et de luminosité donc
là vous avez trois photos une première
photo qui est prise avec le 200
mégapixels l'autre photo qui est prise
en 50 mégapixels on a déjà plus de
lumière on le voit et puis la troisième
photo qui est prise avec le 12 méga
pixels alors on va essayer de comprendre
un peu la différence de ces trois modes
avec le 200 mégapixels on prend la photo
telle qu'elle est je vous le dis un
pixel utilisé est un pixel qui va servir
dans l'image avec le 50 mégapixels c'est
du pixel binding donc on va dire capter
un peu plus de lumière vous le voyez
déjà niveau de la façade ici donc voyez
la chaussure 50 mégapixels c'est un
petit peu plus lumineux là je suis sur
le 200 mégapixels et le 50 mégapixels ça
va être plus clair plus lumineux vous
voyez on vient switcher on a regardé la
différence comme ça et si je passe sur
le 12 mégapixels et bien là on va voir
plus de travail algorithmique on le voit
déjà hein regardez il y a moins de
définition moins de détails au niveau du
ciel c'est moi joli là vous voyez sur le
200 mégapixels là j'ai l'impression que
il y a une petite compression qui a été
faite au niveau de mon fichier ici au
niveau de mon image pour autant on vient
plus effectivement contrasté donc cette
image quand même vachement plus
contrastée par rapport aux 50 et par
rapport aux 200 et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que on voit que l'algorithme
a bossé le blanc sur les fenêtres et
assez clair et le côté brique est
beaucoup plus foncé donc le travail
algorithmique il se fait réellement ici
alors qu'avant l'image elle est un peu
plus plate là elle apporte un peu plus
de contraste vous voyez entre le 200
mégapixels qui va être un peu plus terne
globalement un peu plus foncé avec le 50
mégapixels qui vient s'éclairer et là on
est équilibre un petit peu tout avec ce
12 mégapixels donc ça dépend ce qu'on
veut avoir je dirais qu'en mode
automatique vous mettez en 12 mégapixels
c'est très bien si vous voulez un truc
un peu plus proche de la réalité et
venir retoucher derrière bien 200
mégapixels pour recadrer ou le 50
mégapixels avec la techno du pixel
binding il y a c'est intéressant et
maintenant on va venir se faire des
photos un peu plus classiquement avec le
12 mégapixels et on va faire un truc
comme ça on va regarder le 12 mégapixel
en foin on va passer en X06 l'ultra
grand-angle va regarder les deux télés
objectifs vous savez vous avez deux
TELUS objectif de 10 mégapixels chacun
avec un zoom optique x 3 l'autre avec un
zoom optique x 10 donc les deux cas on
est sur un zoom optique ça c'est très
chouette pour la préservation de la
qualité et après on va monter jusqu'au
space zoom fois 100 et on va regarder
s'il y a une évolution si ça
intéressante il faut y aller ou alors
absolument pas alors là on va regarder
par rapport aux 12 mégapixels là on
reste au même endroit on va venir mettre
grand angle ultra grand-angle et après
on se rapproche x 3 x 10 x 30 x 50 x 100
donc bon c'est vrai que ça c'est quand
même vachement bien fait alors le détail
au niveau des nuages je les ai sympa et
bien on voit que c'est plus contrasté
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure et lorsque je passe sur l'ultra
grand-angle alors ce qui est très
chouette déjà avec l'ultra grand-angle
c'est que j'ai l'impression d'avoir
exactement la même colorimétrie d'images
entre le grand angle et l'ultra
grand-angle ça c'est plutôt bien lorsque
j'aimerais rapprocher pareil je reste
dans la même chose là je suis en zoom
optique x 3 là je suis en zoom optique x
10 donc on se parle bien ici d'optique
on n'est pas sur un Z générique et là
après je vais zoomer effectivement en
numérique c'est en X 30 là je vais
monter jusqu'en x 100 voilà le X 100 il
est là c'est le maximum donc une fois de
plus le X 100 est pas terrible x 30 x 50
on peut venir bricoler au-delà de ça
c'est gadget et accessoires néanmoins ce
qui est intéressant c'est que si le ciel
on le voit bien il est bien préservé
j'ai bien taille de ma façade j'ai bien
mon petit buisson là mon herbe est verte
la couleur me paraît très juste donc ça
c'est bien peut-être un petit quota un
peu plus Viola c'est un peu bleu au
niveau du ciel par rapport au
grand-angle une petite différence mais
ça ne pas déconnant x 3 x 10 x 10 c'est
correct ça me paraît pas mal à voir on
va continuer à regarder de temps x 50
c'est là en x 100 pareil de la même
manière ici on va regarder au niveau du
ciel notamment l'ultra grand-angle et
une petite différence de colosse un peu
plus saturée en fait regardez sur la
brique là si vous regardez entre le
grand angle là et l'ultra grand-angle et
on vient zoomer on vient voir ok c'est
pas mal pareil ici grand angle ultra
grand-angle donc voilà la différence au
niveau de la brique vous voyez au niveau
de la lumière et on vient se rapprocher
un peu dans l'image et on va choper
jusqu'au bout ce qui se passe ici voyez
même exercice donc normalement je trouve
ça ça marche bien c'est très joli et là
j'aime bien voyez je pars donc là je
suis très grand angle le X 3 le X 10
j'aime cette photo je la trouve assez
joli c'est un X 30 bon le poisson on
oublie pareil ici je voulais vraiment
voir avec ce que ça va compter derrière
avec le ciel comme ça et alors on va
vraiment la différence de colorimétrie
c'est beaucoup plus bleu en fait sur
l'ultra grand-angle et ça marche ça
c'est doux c'est assez joli ça marche
bon les crottes de nez on oublie ici
pareil à Bastille même exercice on peut
venir se rapprocher et en fait c'est une
fois de plus un gars une amélioration on
le voit logiciel ici qui est là bon
après il vient de métropole ça sert
absolument à rien sur ce fichier là j'ai
voulu venir regarder pour voir
effectivement si on pouvait venir lire
très facilement on peut venir lire très
facilement donc une fois de plus Samsung
reste mettre ici nous propose des
fichiers de bonne qualité c'est très
sympa on va pas aller au-delà du X 30 ça
sert à rien parce que globalement on ira
pas bien loin on va aussi maintenant
regarder ce qui se passe du côté de la
caméra de selfie parce que vous voyez il
y a une caméra de selfie de l'autre côté
on peut faire des photos et on va
regarder si ça intéresse on d'autant
plus que la résolution et la baissé
entre ce qu'on avait sur le S22 ultra et
ce qu'on a ici sur le S23 ultra on nous
dit que c'est par rapport à l'autofocus
donc on va voir si c'est vrai ça marche
bien c'est intéressant ou pas une fois
plus on regarde voilà le selfie je
trouve pas mal là je trouve assez
contrasté quand même au niveau du visage
là où on a beaucoup de smartphone
chinois notamment j'ai vu avec le Xiaomi
à 13 pro je trouve que c'est un petit
peu trop lissé je sortirai d'ailleurs
une vidéo sur des images sur le Xiaomi
13 pro d'ici quelques jours ça c'est pas
mal ça c'est contrasté ça c'est joli
alors là il y a un truc vous voyez c'est
là où on voit un peu la limite du truc
c'est quand on vient de pousser avec un
fond trop blanc et bien il vient
compenser il faut une espèce de
détourage pour bien avoir mes petits
cheveux je les ai les trois il est là
mais il y a une espèce de Halo d'ange
autour de ma tronche qui est un peu trop
poussif à côté de ça le traitement du
visage est pas mal là c'est pareil
derrière c'est bien et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que une fois de plus
vous voyez mes petits cheveux et ben ils
sont pas perdus je les ai bien j'ai
vraiment du détail donc ça c'est toi que
j'ai vraiment repéré ici là alors et en
plus une fonction où on est en foin et
on est en x 0,8 donc on vient légèrement
reculer un peu dans l'image toujours sur
la même optique il y en a pas d'autre
donc ça fait le taf j'aime bien la
colorimétrie je la trouve bien est-ce
que je vais reprocher souvent au
smartphone chinois je vous dis ça lisse
la salise pas les Coréens ont très bien
beau c'est ça c'est super chouette et
quand on se parle de filmer au
smartphone on se parle de 8k ici on a de
la 8k 30 images par seconde là où on
avait une dernière la 8k 24 images par
seconde donc on est venu en gagner
gratter quelques images en plus alors
pour le commun des mortels on s'en fout
mais par contre pour des gens qui
veulent aller plus loin faire j'en sais
rien plus de broadcast audiovisuel
peut-être avec un smartphone allez
savoir en tout cas on peut le faire là
je suis en train de filmer en 8k à 30
images par seconde l'idée pour moi c'est
regarder la stabilité moi je
tremblements donc là je le prends dans
la main qui tremble le plus on regarde
si ça fonctionne alors je suis sur un
petit perche de Joby là dites-moi vous
ce que vous en pensez est-ce que ça fait
le temps parce que ça a l'air de faire
le taf on change demain de ce que j'ai
vu en tout cas ça n'est plutôt
prometteur mais plutôt efficace là où
l'année dernière ça bouge un peu donc je
pense que ça c'est toute la puissance de
calcul du stand dragon 8 GN 2 qui vient
vraiment permettre cette grosse capacité
de calcul pour nous apporter cette
stabilisation en plus donc là on va
redescendre maintenant en 4K à 60 images
par seconde donc là je suis en 4K 60
images par seconde c'est ce que j'ai
filmé depuis le début donc vous avez
déjà vu l'image on va redescendre
maintenant en 4K à 30 images par seconde
donc je pense au globalement ici vu
qu'on fait un export en 25 images par
seconde ça va globalement pas changer
grand chose pour vous et après on peut
bien évidemment descendre en Full HD à
60 à 30 en 720p si on le souhaite mais
je suis globalement à grand chose et là
je suis sur la caméra de selfie où je
peux filmer au maximum en 4K à 60 images
par seconde alors me direz-vous est-ce
que je vais venir filmer avec cette
caméra là pas forcément moi ce que je
fais c'est que je prends mon petit bras
je tourne mon smartphone et je le place
vraiment face à moi comme ça je sais
réellement ce qu'il en est alors si vous
voulez moins galérer et avoir un
meilleur son la petite astuce c'est de
passer sur l'ultra grand-angle derrière
comme ça vous rapprocher vous avez le
micro qui est plus proche de votre
bouche un peu plus proche de votre
bouche comme ça je vous montre tout ça
donne donc là je suis sur mon ultra
grand-angle je peux pas filmer ici
jusqu'en 8 à 30 images par seconde je
peux filmer ici au maximum jusqu'en 4K
60 images par seconde mais je peux
rapprocher le smartphone alors après
vous me direz ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous aimez le rendu est-ce
qu'il y a pas un côté trop déformant et
je pense que c'est pas mal pour venir
effectivement tenir à la main vloguer
vous êtes sûr tout avoir vous êtes
dedans pas sûr que vous ayez la
meilleure image si jamais vous avez un
peu moins de lumière pas sûr que ce soit
ce qu'il y a de mieux mais si on veut
vloguer vous avez la lumière comme ça ça
peut être très pratique donc pour les
créateurs de contenu ça peut être une
bonne idée alors il y a également
différents modes il y a notamment la
vidéo portrait comme vous avez ici qui
va venir vous apporter ce côté un peu
portrait le côté porter un flou derrière
plan il y a différentes options qu'on
peut venir mettre ici en place je sais
pas si vous aimez bien c'est un truc qui
peut vous tenter alors je déçois en foin
ou en X 3 là je suis en foin là je
recule vraiment ma perche parce que je
suis en X 3 ça vient forcément zoomer et
on passe ici sur je pense en tout cas le
téléobjectif sur le zoom optique x 3
mais bon voilà dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce qu'il y a un intérêt à le
faire comme ça en tout cas à bout de
bras ou pas ou alors ce qu'il faut
derrière que vous ayez un opérateur qui
viennent opérer qui viennent manier
directement les shooter avec votre
smartphone ou alors est-ce que c'est
vous qui allez venir shooter dans ce
mode là pour le coup vous allez avoir
différents effets alors il y a du glitch
il y a plein de trucs c'est marrant si
on a envie de se faire plaisir envie de
s'amuser et avoir un truc un petit peu
fantastique j'en sais rien on peut venir
le chercher ici en tout cas si vous êtes
créatif vous avez une vraie palette de
vrais outils pour venir vous amuser moi
ça me fait marrer cet effet alors ça
c'est peut-être pas le truc le plus
dingue du monde mais je trouve qu'il y a
un côté un peu marrant et puis ce qui
est très cool c'est que comme derrière
vous avez une très grosse capacité de
calcul avec ce stade dragon une nuit
Jane II et ben je trouve que le résultat
est là quand même ça fonctionne on a un
truc qui est efficace je pense que vous
en pensez une fois de plus dites-le-moi
en bas dans les commentaires et puis
après il faut venir essayer par soi-même
pour voir s'il y a un intérêt pour vous
pour les usages oui non tout ça etc on a
également la vue du réalisateur c'est
pas nouveau c'est déjà arrivé avant où
je vais m'avoir moi sans ma caméra de
selfie et je vais avoir mes trois
voyages les principales là c'est la
caméra principale je vais avoir toute la
scène arrière avec le X 3 avec le X
comme ça je peux venir switcher je peux
venir inverser passer moi directement à
l'avant et ensuite venir changer une
fois de plus ma petite incrustation avec
mes différentes caméras donc le truc est
assez rigolo je sais pas si c'est
vraiment intéressant une fois de plus
c'est un truc qui nous sort un seul et
même fichier moi je voudrais qu'on
puisse avoir différents fichiers pour
que ça aille vraiment ensemble mais vous
voyez c'est pas le cas ici je peux venir
agrandir je peux venir je pense le
déplacer également donc pour certains
créatifs why not en tout cas que ça ait
un intérêt pour vous tout en sachant
qu'avec ce mode je suis uniquement en
Full HD donc tout ça relativement
limitatif ça sera intéressant de pouvoir
arriver avec de la 4K pour pouvoir
effectivement l'exploiter pleinement
aujourd'hui il faut l'acheter si on veut
mais ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est pas de
filmer en Full HD moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de venir filmer en 4K et ça une
fois de plus c'est toujours pas possible
donc bon voilà il nous reste un dernier
mode pour venir prendre des photos c'est
le fameux mode portrait qui pour le coup
va être extrêmement intéressant avec ce
stade dragon 8 GN2 qui va permettre avec
sa grosse capacité de calcul vous sortir
un détourage millimétré un détourage
parfait quasiment on va regarder ça
alors le mode portrait je tiens à la
main sur ma perche donc bon c'est pas
parfait là c'est un poil flou mais c'est
pas la photo que j'ai eu à prendre
exemple j'ai trouvé un peu un peu
moyenne est-ce qu'il y a un du coup je
sais pas ça c'est un petit peu mieux je
suis pas trop mal détouré mais une fois
de plus il aurait fallu que quelqu'un le
tienne et ne bouge pas ne tremble pas
sur une perche le rendu et pas trop mal
on voit que ça détour bien mais il y a
un côté un petit peu flou donc il
faudrait le tester encore différemment
donc on regardera ça un peu plus tard
également lors du test vous voyez c'est
un premier jet alors bon il y a
différents modes de mode portrait que je
suis venu voir effectivement ça détour
pas trop mal voyez ça a coupé légèrement
un peu au niveau de mes cheveux là on
voit un peu le bâtiment derrière alors
moi j'ai les cheveux gris un truc gris
derrière donc fatalement ça fout un peu
le bordel ça marche moins bien ça c'est
pas trop mal donc tu as les trucs qui
sont assez rigolos en fait voilà pour
cette partie photo vidéo maintenant je
vous regarde un petit peu le côté
performance parce que c'est un premier
jet une fois de plus mais je suis venu
faire un benchmark sur un toutou pour
regarder parce que c'est génial qu'on
est ce processeur de Qualcomm ici ce
Snapdragon 8 gène 2 donc on va regarder
comment il se positionne par rapport au
reste du marché alors regardez je lui ai
trouvé le score sur un toutou de 1
million
223307 et je vais le mettre en face du
Xiaomi à 13 pro qui lui a également un
sein dragon 8 GN2 et là je suis un peu
plus élevé j'ai un million
42 669 ça joue globalement à pas grand
chose ce qui fait que ici ça va
effectivement être alors est-ce qu'on a
la même version j'ai la même version de
antutu benchmax c'est la 9.4.7 ça c'est
aussi important à venir regarder et si
je viens regarder en fait le classement
ici que ça me propose ça vient me
positionner mon smartphone en combien
tiennent position mais ça me le met en
3e position après le vivo X90 pro plus à
un million 290000 après le hiku 127000
et ça me le propose là alors en fait par
rapport à ce que je vois ici il serait
normalement après le Xiaomi 13 pro qui
lui n'apparaît pas dans ce classement
donc en fait il serait plutôt en
quatrième position mais on voit qu'on
est quand même devant le rock fan 6 donc
ça va bouger parce que au fur et à
mesure qu'il y a d'autres smartphones
qui vont sortir avec descendre 8 GN2 ça
va venir s'affiner mais en tout cas ce
qu'on voit et ce qui est génial c'est
que on n'est pas en bas du classement je
pense que si on était sur un exinos on
serait probablement un poil plus bas
donc là on est dans la course entre 1
million 223000 et 1 million
272000 bon ça se tient donc de toute
façon ce qui va être intéressant au-delà
du benchmark pur si regardez ce que ça
raconte en termes de fluidité en termes
d'usage ça c'est toi qui va vraiment me
plaire donc moi je suis assez content
d'avoir vu ce smartphone pour l'instant
les premières images je les trouve
intéressantes j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
venir l'utiliser je trouve stabiliser
sur les 8 à 30 images par seconde il y a
vraiment très jolie chose donc on en
reparle très bientôt de ce smartphone
donc bien évidemment ce que je vous
invite à faire et bien c'est à dire vous
abonner actionner la cloche et puis me
dire tout ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires si vous avez des questions
allez-y j'essaierai de vous répondre
lors de mon test voilà et puis rester
connecté parce que très bientôt on va
parler des S23 S23 plus j'ai plein de
choses à vous raconter je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
Ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]